Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively are one
of Hollywood's favorite power couples
I'm
I'm paired up with my best friend you
know when that happens you you recognize
how unbelievably lucky you are and now
ETS looking back at their superhero
origin story
do you think I'm irresponsible
and why fans can't get enough of their
A-list romance she really does just show
me how to be better in almost every way
back in the odds Ryan was already
kicking butt on the big screen while
blakestar was on the rise as one of
Gossip girl's upper East Side teens you
did not just do that then in 2011 they
got matched up on screen playing love
interests in Green Lantern it's
impossible not to get along with him
yeah Blake and Ryan's chemistry jumped
off the big screen and into real life
and the Stars said I do the following
year when your sister started dating
Ryan I would imagine you have to get the
seal of approval from your sis was it an
easy yes for you 100 yeah
so wonderful and as their careers got
bigger so did the family it's very
different getting dressed with a
watermelon as a stomach Blake gave birth
to their first child daughter James in
2014. have you figured it all out yet
the parenting thing you could ask me
about 90 years and I'm gonna say you
know you look at this little face you
think I'm only gonna know this person
for you know hopefully 50
25 years you know it doesn't suddenly it
doesn't seem like a long time and like
most actors Blake and Ryan love a sequel
they welcomed another baby girl Inez in
2016.
when Ryan got his star on the Walk of
Fame the whole fam was on hand to
celebrate the Milestone this only
happens once in a lifetime and and
normally we don't Trot the whole family
out like this but uh but I just thought
I would regret this in 20 years if I
didn't have my kids here as well so so
we all we decided to collectively just
come down here in one big movement and
be a part of this Flash Forward three
years later Blake surprised fans with a
baby bump at Ryan's Pokemon movie
premiere
foreign
yep the couple welcomed their third
daughter Betty in 2019 who'd already
made her red carpet debut Pokemon in
general is like catnip to Children
he's adorable you're adorable yep I'm
doing it I'm in I need more of that
validation for my child and did we
mention Blake and Ryan love being
parents for under 10 years old how
excited are you and Blake I'm we're very
excited you know uh we'd have to be you
know you'd have to be a [ __ ] to do this
four times if you didn't like it as the
two celebrated their 10th wedding
anniversary in September Blake once
again hid the carpet to reveal another
bundle of Joys on the way in Hollywood
years that's like 145 years we've been
together I think so how do you guys do
it yeah well we like each other yeah
important yeah you know it's always a
good foundation for any relationship
[Music]